I'm Abby hornacek I'm Ben Dominic I'm
Dana Perino and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday November 2nd 2022 I'm Bill
hemmer less than one week before the
2022 midterm elections Republican
candidates are reportedly making major
games and the GOP is projecting major
confidence about taking control of
Congress on issue after issue what the
people are talking about is do I have is
my life better off than it was two years
ago and if the answer is no then why
would you vote for the people who are in
charge I'm Lisa Brady Republican midterm
momentum has Democrats shifting gears
the polling and also the money being
spent right now suggests that Democrats
are very concerned about races in very
blue parts of the country from
California to Oregon and I'm Mark
Thiessen I've got the final word on the
Fox News Rundown
[Music]
We Stand less than a week before the
midterm elections and what was once
considered to be a close election season
has changed dramatically in the last two
weeks with poll margins Whiting in
several key States the Democrats have
brought former president Barack Obama on
the campaign Trail to headline rallies
in Battleground States many see this
move as an effort to avoid tying
Democrats to President Biden as midterms
draw near with the president's approval
ratings hovering in the low 40s and even
30s for the past several weeks election
day is approaching fast and control over
Washington hangs in the balance with
many voters saying they trust
Republicans the most on issues like the
economy and crime the GOP is projecting
major confidence about their chances of
taking power this election cycle well I
think we're in a good position to take
back the house Ronald McDaniel is the
chairwoman for the Republican National
Committee we need five seats to take
back the house because of the Great wins
that we had in 2020 where we didn't lose
a single incumbent in the house and
picked up 15 seats and blue areas so the
house we need five seats four of those
could just come from Florida just to
give you an example the Senate's toss-up
Senate's neck and neck in Pennsylvania
in Georgia and Nevada we feel good about
what we're seeing with Republican
turnout but it's all going to come down
to election day like every other
election which makes a lot of sense
broadly speaking last week just about
every story written said the same thing
Republicans are on a roll I don't know
if that changes this week however I
think we should be wide open to the
possibility that the story swings back
to the Democrats yet again do you see
that happening or not I don't because we
were saying this all summer the big
issue was the economy and Democrats
really tried to shift it to abortion
they put millions and millions and
millions of dollars behind abortion and
where did voters come back home to the
economy that is the issue that is
driving this election because people are
really hurting in the Northeast when
they have home heating oil prices
topping out in some cases seven dollars
a gallon on top of gas prices being high
on top of inflation with groceries with
rent with all the different things that
people have to pay for it is really
causing an economic crunch for everyday
Americans and that is the number one
issue driving this election and people
are holding the Democrats accountable so
that's because they have the Senate the
house and the white house now Nevada the
early vote dominated by Dems based on
history we are hearing anecdotally that
they do not have the type of lead that
you would normally expect what are you
hearing about Nevada today similar in
Nevada Pennsylvania Georgia we're just
not seeing the Dem turn out at the level
that they've had in the past now it
doesn't mean that they're not going to
turn out on Election Day because habits
have changed and we're coming out of a
pandemic where that election really you
can't use as a model for 2022 and laws
have changed as well especially in
Nevada so but what we're seeing
anecdotally is not the same lead that
they would have in Clark County usually
the Democrats will go into election date
with the size of a lead in absentee and
mail-in voting Democrats prefer mail-in
voting Republicans prefer election day
voting that's just I haven't we've seen
form over the past several elections and
we're just not seeing those leads built
but we have a week so I'm not going to
get overconfident
there's going to be a lot of talk about
Virginia too all right that's a district
Southeastern corner of the state
um it's Hampton Roads two good
candidates Elaine Lauria won her contest
four years ago she's trying to keep her
seat for a third time she's being
challenged by Jen kiggins a a
well-regarded republican both women by
the way have military records the
district has been redrawn to slightly
favor the Republican the reason I point
to that race is because it's Virginia
they close at seven o'clock and they
count fast likewise I would say for
Florida 27 which is Miami and Maria
Salazar is running for re-election there
is a republican how will she do you can
compare the numbers now to what she did
four years ago when she lost the
dinosaur Layla granted things are
different now however you could still
base an apples to let's say somewhat
Apple's comparison I don't know if you
agree with that or not but that's what
I'm saying Florida counts fast that part
of Florida closes at seven o'clock New
Hampshire one there's a really good
house race there in the southern part of
that state we think New Hampshire counts
pretty fast as well do you agree with
those three on the table that I just put
out there or would you suggest others no
I do I do agree I think you're right to
go to the states that vote that we that
count fast I mean New York you're not
going to get a quick result right we
know that there's a lot of races in New
York that'll be pivotal but I think
those are good races I think Maria
Salazar is a great one to look at to see
if she wins overwhelmingly I will say
Florida in general we have four
potential pickups in Florida Corey Mills
Aaron Bean Laurel Lee and Anna Paulina
Luna if we get those four that means
we're one away from taking back the
house obviously there's other races that
are you know we're on the defense on and
we're on the offense on but just Florida
alone can deliver you know the vast
majority of what we need to take back
the speakership so Florida reports early
Jen kiggins is in a neck and neck race I
would add George Logan in Connecticut
and um Alan Fung in Rhode Island I don't
know how quickly those results come in
but those are going to be some East
Coast races that if they flip it
probably means it's going to be a very
good night I can't recall an election
where we even paid attention to
Connecticut or Rhode Island exactly I
mean George Logan we opened an office
the rnc's opened these community centers
Hispanic Asian black we actually have a
Native American Community Center as well
in these historically Democrat voting
areas trying to take our message to
minority voters and one of our first
ones that we opened was in George
Logan's district and and I think being
there in a for a whole year from the RNC
and then giving these candidates a
platform or a building or a place to
meet voters is going to be a Difference
Maker the other one you mentioned was
Rhode Island two now there was a
republican there by the name of Alan
Fung he's a former mayor of Cranston
Rhode Island we have heard his name for
three months why one he's he's been
ahead in the polls consistently it is it
is narrow going but he's likable and
he's working hard and he's got a great
message and the other thing is the
Democrats are being held accountable for
what's happening in this country and I
mean on issue after issue what the
people are talking about is do I have is
my life better off than it was two years
ago and if the answer is no then why
would you vote for the people who are in
charge why would you put them back in
office and that's where you're seeing
Independence come to our party and
though that's where they'll be in play
in in States like Rhode Island
Connecticut also in Oregon and
Washington State and Illinois I mean
there's pickups all across the board for
republicans
the Republican Congressional committee
money in three districts that have been
off the map for some time
one is in Upstate New York Rochester New
York 25. there's a former police
commissioner who's running as a
republican to try and win that race
crime's a big deal in Rochester
Pittsburgh which is Pennsylvania 12. and
California 26 which is the Los Angeles
area
these are deep blue districts they might
be plus 20 Dems they might be plus 20
Biden are pretty close to it is that a
legitimate money spent or is that a head
is that a head fake this late in the
cycle I think it is I think in this type
of cycle if it ends up being a wave
which we're not going to know until
everybody goes and votes on Election Day
and goes to gop.com to find where they
need to vote you're going to pick up C2
didn't expect and so what we're seeing
right now is Republicans are expanding
the map and Democrats are Contracting
right so they just pulled out of for
example or they're limiting their spend
in Wisconsin three the old Ron kind
District where Dr Van Orton is running
or David schweikert's District in
Arizona that they saw as a potential
pickup you know Kevin McCarthy and I got
to give him a lot of credit he has
recruited a phenomenal slate of
candidates and he has raised a lot of
money that is allowing us to play in
districts that you know a year ago would
have been unheard of
if you were to throw a dart at the map
and say this is what I'm looking at with
Keen interest where would that Dart land
well it probably would land right now in
Washington state which we probably won't
have results on but I think Tiffany
Smiley is making a run for this senate
seat and I think if that falls our way
we're winning seats nobody expected but
she's neck and neck with Patty Murray
there's two polls right now having her
either one behind her tied she has taken
the Patty Murray phrase of mom in
running shoes and she's adopted it on
her own and said Patty Murray you are no
longer a mom in running shoes you are a
Washington Insider and I'm the new mob
in running shoes and Tiffany is just a
phenomenal candidate I would also say
Tudor Dixon I'm going to watch her
because she's from my home state in
Michigan the issue there is education is
it not yeah education is the big issue
in Michigan I mean Detroit schools are
failed I'm one of those moms who's mad
my son was virtual for a year and a half
it's just really shameful what's
happened to these kids and parents are
very angry and I think that's the
undercurrent that's not totally being
pulled well because they're not just
democrat or republican they're just
parents who are very upset about the
aftermath of the pandemic and the
learning loss that our kids are still
dealing with phenomenal very interesting
last question if this goes the way some
people have projected and it's a blowout
the focus will be on the policies of
President Biden and Democrats and what
they've pursued
how much thought have you given to how
much they would change as a result
I think that's a
Joe Biden as he said I'm going to bring
people together I'm going to unite
people are really exhausted by the
division and not really suffering and so
you know when Bill Clinton lost and that
historic election in 1994 he came to the
middle remember he went from welfare to
work very adopted a lot of Republican
ideals because because he was repudiated
with Hillary care and some of the things
he was pursuing in his first two years
so we'll see if Joe Biden will come to
the middle I know that if we win
decisively the American people are
saying cut it out Washington get your
act together and start working on behalf
of our problems and our issues and I
know Republicans are focused on that
we'll see what happens come Election Day
November 8th Ronald McDaniel thank you
so much for your time today thanks Bill
thanks for having me
foreign
[Music]
this is Mark Thiessen with your Fox News
commentary coming up
President Biden keeps warning voters
what might happen if Republicans Take
Back Control of Congress well I've come
to Florida today to talk about two very
very very important programs he says
Social Security and Medicare will be on
the chopping block you've been paying
the Social Security your whole life
you earned it now these guys want to
take it away who in the hell do they
think they are excuse my language
it's part of the president's closing
argument in the midterm elections and he
followed that event yesterday with
what's been rare for him a joint
appearance with Democratic candidates
Republicans say the president is lying
because Democrats are failing on the
issues especially inflation Biden said
that he wouldn't raise taxes on the
middle class but if you're a family
right now dealing with the grocery
prices and the energy prices certainly
you feel like your taxes have gone up a
lot because the cost of living a good
life in this country has gone up a lot
Ohio Senate hopeful J.D Vance during a
Fox News Town Hall last night the
Democrat in that race Congressman Tim
Ryan appearing separately and saying he
still thinks the inflation reduction act
will help going forward but he knows
it's not providing immediate relief and
he would support tax cuts I don't have
control over everybody else I think this
is the solution I've been streaming at
Democrats too for a year and a half
to pass a tax cut that's the short term
that raise for outgoing Republican
senator Rob Portman's seat is listed as
lean Republican in the final Fox News
power rankings of the midterms the
forecast shows the Senate still up for
grabs overall hinging on several toss-up
States but the house moving toward a
bigger expected Republican majority for
Democrats to keep control they would
need to win all 26 house races
considered toss-ups and six more where
Republicans have the advantage well look
the big picture right now is that
Democrats are concerned that there could
be a very significant red wave that hits
the political landscape where
Republicans take back the house with a
pretty comfortable majority Fox News
Radio political analyst Josh crossauer
is a senior political correspondent for
axios and that they win the Senate and
possibly some of these really close
toss-up races break their way in the end
the polling and also the money being
spent right now suggests that Democrats
are very concerned about races in very
blue parts of the country from
California to Oregon to New York and at
the same time the Senate races that
we're watching the most closely like
Pennsylvania Georgia Nevada all look
very very close margin of error type
races where you know in a wave it tends
to go one way it tends to go favoring
the party out of power but look we're
talking about some flawed candidates for
the Republicans in these races and these
are very competitive to the very end
let's dive in to some of what you said
first of all in the Senate those handful
of states that have been toss-ups
basically all along those races seem to
have only gotten tighter what is making
those States So Close first of all a lot
of Voters who are undecided who don't
pay attention to politics like you and I
do tend to make their decisions very
late because they don't follow politics
they're focusing on their pocketbooks
they're focusing on economic issues and
they're not happy with the state of the
economy they're not happy with Rising
Goods at the grocery store at the
gasoline pump so you're seeing these
races getting a lot closer because a lot
of these undecided voters are breaking
against the party in power they're
breaking against the Democratic party
and if that continues up until election
day that could give Republicans a narrow
but significant advantage in their
battle to retake the Senate majority
the final Fox News power rankings for
the midterms not really offering a path
for Democrats to try and keep the house
anymore with more of the close races
they're shifting toward the GOP is that
mainly about the economy and crime
it's about a lot of factors but the fact
that the economy is in rough shape
volatile shape and the fact that you
know Democrats hold the White House they
hold both branches of Congress so
they're the ones that are viewed by
voters as being fully in charge uh and
with such a narrow majority that Nancy
Pelosi holds in the house it just takes
five seats to flip and when you factor
in both redistricting which may gain
Republicans a couple seats and just the
overall mood of the country it's easy to
see how Republicans are heavily favored
to to win back the majority I I would
expect that we'll have an early call on
Election night on Republicans being
heavily favored uh and maybe
accomplishing the goal of retaking the
house in 2022. there's been a lot of
talk about Suburban women and Hispanics
and maybe shifting toward the Republican
party and what issues are moving them
are we seeing shifts that should be
concerning for either party when it
comes to those voting blocks yeah well
we're seeing something of I don't want
to call it a realignment because it's a
little too broad for what we're seeing
but we're seeing Hispanic voters
non-white voters working class voters of
all Races tilting a little bit more
towards the Republicans that we've seen
uh in quite some time and we all are
also seeing the Suburban vote had been
moving more towards the Democrats the
the upscale Suburban vote had become in
a much more reliably Democratic
constituency though I will say that in
this election Republicans have made a
major comeback to some inroads with
Independent Women in the suburbs so that
was a constituency that because of the
abortion decision the Dobbs decision in
the summer those voters tended to lean
Democratic but now they're much more in
play if not already leaning back towards
the Republicans again each party accuses
the other of being extreme or radical is
that Fear Factor making a difference or
were the candidates always considered
too far to one side never doing well in
this election cycle um you know
Pennsylvania's Republican candidate for
governor Doug mastriano comes to mind
so I think it's fair to say that being
extreme whether you're a Republican or
you're a Democrat you're paying a pretty
sizable political price so you mentioned
the Pennsylvania Governor's race Doug
mastriano is likely to lose that race
and possibly by a pretty big margin at a
time when Republicans are doing well
across the board not just in
Pennsylvania but but across the East
Coast so that that is an example of
someone who's very extreme who takes
positions outside where your average
Pennsylvania voter is who's paying a big
price but um and you also see it in
Arizona and New Hampshire these are
actually close races but I think
Republicans will be in better shape
right now if they had a more if Doug
Ducey was running for Senate instead of
Blake Masters if Chris Newton was
running for Senate instead of Don
balduck that said the Democrats are also
paying a price for nominating some
extreme candidates or weak candidates in
important races just look at Wisconsin
and the senate race in Wisconsin where
you know Ron Johnson was beatable in
this election his numbers are very
polarizing and but Mandela Barnes the
lieutenant governor has taken positions
on crime has taken positions on policing
has given interviews to Russian
television done things that are just
making him very unpopular in the eyes of
Wisconsin voters making him oh fairly
weak Democratic Challenger to Ron
Johnson and he's trailing consistently
now in the polls in Wisconsin you know
Herschel Walker is another example in
Georgia where you know flawed Republican
candidates are put in some seats that
shouldn't be close or now very very
close but Democrats are also squandering
opportunities like in Wisconsin with
Mandela Barnes also in Pennsylvania
that's a very winnable seat for
Democrats but between John fetterman's
health and his own positions on criminal
justice issues he is also putting uh
jeopardizing that seat for Democrats and
creating an opportunity for Republicans
to hold that seat with Dr Oz
what kind of turnout is expected at this
point I know for Democrats it's
especially key to draw the younger
voters the African-American voters but
the Republican party chair Ronald
McDaniel has also been emphasizing that
get out the vote message
yeah I mean look I expect High turnout
we've seen historic turnout in the last
two elections so you know it's hard to
predict without actually getting to
election day but I I would expect higher
than average turnout I think the bigger
question is which party does a better
job of turning out their core voters
with Republicans being the party out of
power that doesn't take as much work to
get those voters to the polls Democrats
are really in some states struggling to
get their core voters to show up and
prove to their voters that this election
really does matter
how much of an impact can a governor's
race have on a tight Senate race or has
that tendency changed over time are
voters more or less likely to split
their ticket in this polarized political
climate we have well the governor's
races are the last Bastion of
partisanship in many ways and we are
seeing voters more likely to be
independent minded when it comes to
their choice for governor the the
Congressional races who which party is
going to control the Senate and the
house those are a lot more partisan
they're a lot more ideological so um you
know you're going to see split ticket
votes but that's nothing that new
Governors have always been seen as
separate because they're not in
Washington they're they're closer to the
ground in your home state whereas
Congress you know it's a little more
distant it's a little more abstract and
people tend to especially these days
tend to vote more on partisan lines than
on individual lines one quick question
for you about surrogates on the campaign
Trail because the White House you know
says the president's been making the
case about his agenda until recently
though with candidates he's been mostly
behind the scenes receptions and the
like
um while former president Obama was
holding the big rallies
um you know is that the right strategy
for Democrats and then on the other side
you've got you know former president
Trump front and center with a lot of
candidates holding a lot of rallies
um does his presence maybe backfire for
republicans in certain areas yeah well
um it's not a good sign when the
president of your party is not really
welcome and in many of these
battlegrounds States I know he's going
to be in Pennsylvania this week he's
going to Florida which in those races
seem lost for the Democrats so maybe
there's not as much risk in Florida
Biden's closing out in Maryland the the
blue state of Maryland
um as his final election pre-election
stopped so you know it's the fact that
he's not welcome in some of these
classic swing States because the
Democrats don't think it'll be a drag on
their campaigns tells you everything you
need to know you know Obama may be the
most popular surrogate but he's a former
president he didn't do that well when he
was president in these midterm elections
I really don't think he's going to have
a major impact in turning out Democratic
voters uh you know as far as Republicans
go Trump is sort of the the big wild
card
um the areas of the country he's going
into are more rural more conservative
more Maga oriented he also is not going
into some of these classic swing States
so I will say Pennsylvania is one of one
of his stops and that's a a race where
Dr Oz has moved to the middle and moved
more to the mainstream in his general
election campaign but he also is going
pointed another the second Trump rally
alongside a much more polarizing and
unpopular of Republican gubernatorial
nominee and Doug mastriano so you know
that that is a risky move for if you're
a republican that's trying to run to the
middle of the electorate to be seen with
Trump in the final days may help
energize your base and maybe Oz needs
the base to show up in a little more
significant of a number but it also
risks turning off those suburban swing
voters who make the difference in so
many important elections last question
for you is there one race that has
surprised you the most leading up to
these midterms or you know is it the
climate of the overall election cycle in
some way yeah well you know I think it's
surprising that the Oregon and New York
Governor's races Morgan hasn't elected a
republican since 1982. you have to go
back to the Cuomo years to see when a
republican last held the or Pataki was
the last Republican Governor it's been a
while since the Republican has held
either one of those Governor's mansions
in these deep blue States and yet polls
and all the reporting I've done suggests
that they're both extremely competitive
and winnable for the Republican Party
the political analyst Josh crossauer
thank you so much for your time thanks
again
and in other news I'm Gianna jalosi air
Travelers tend to either favor window
seats or aisle seats but one Airline is
trying to give you a little incentive to
sandwich yourself between the two Virgin
Australia launched its middle seat
lottery for those who either Choose Or
are assigned a middle seat selected
passengers on board the Airlines
domestic flights will have the chance to
win part of the 230 000 Australian
dollars worth of prizes that are up for
grabs including free cruises on Virgin
voyages a helicopter pub crawl an
adventure package complete with bungee
jumping and giant swinging and automatic
loyalty status with the airline and one
million points Virgin Australia
conducted a survey earlier this year and
found less than one percent of people
intentionally select the middle seat as
their first seat preference 62 percent
favor the aisle 35 percent favored the
window three percent say any seat is
fine by them the lottery is going to run
until April 23rd with a winner selected
every week after the announcement was
posted on the airline's social media
channels some commenters agreed that
this is a brilliant plan but others said
there is nothing that could ever get
them to sit in that middle seat for the
Fox News rundown I'm gianjulosi
[Music]
new from the Fox News podcasts Network
my name is Kennedy and welcome to my
podcast which will I humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's Kennedy Saves the World
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com Raiden review the Fox
News rundown on Apple podcasts or
wherever you listen it's time for your
Fox News commentary Mark Thiessen what's
on your mind John fetterman's painful
debate performance has raised a vital
question for Pennsylvania voters does
the Democrat have just speech and
auditory processing issues or did his
stroke leave him with serious cognitive
impairment if his stroke damaged his
ability to hear and speak but not to
think many voters might not care after
all the federmen were deaf and needed
closed captioning to understand what
people were saying or if he had a speech
impediment that made it difficult for
him to verbally communicate few would
question his Fitness for office but if
his stroke damaged his ability to
understand and process information and
thus make competent decisions about
serious public policy issues that is an
entirely different story
many people have no cognitive
complications after suffering a stroke
but according to an article in the
medical journal stroke quote more than
40 percent of stroke survivors are found
with cognitive impairment post-stroke
cognitive impairment or psci sometime
after the event almost two-thirds of
these are affected by mild cognitive
impairment and a meta-analysis showed 10
percent developed dementia soon after a
first stroke and more than a third had
dementia after a recurrence stroke
unquote there are several clinical tests
to determine whether a patient is
experiencing cognitive impairment in
2018 when some were questioning
president Donald Trump's cognitive
Fitness for office Trump asked his White
House doctors to administer a test
called the Montreal cognitive assessment
which he reportedly passed with flying
colors the test is 30 points and
designed to take 10 minutes a score of
26 or greater is considered normal 18 to
25 is considered mild cognitive
impairment 10 to 17 is considered
moderate cognitive impairment and a
score of less than 10 is considered
severe cognitive impairment there are
other cognitive tests federmen could
take such as the many mental state
examination or the cognitive assessment
scale for stroke patients which is
specifically designed to assess
post-stroke cognitive impairments in
patients like fetterman who appears to
have severe expressive Aphasia which is
a loss of the ability to understand or
Express speech has fetterman taken any
of these tests if so what were the
results we don't know the answers
because fetterman has not been
transparent about his condition he won't
release his medical records which would
show the results of any cognitive test
he might have taken after Trump wonder
when his assessment his then White House
doctor Ronnie Jackson spent nearly an
hour taking questions from the media to
White House news briefing but fetterman
won't make his doctor available to the
media so reporters can't ask what
testing did the candidate undergo or ask
about the details of his cognitive
prognosis fetterman has a history of
being less than forthcoming about his
medical condition recall that his
campaign waited nearly two days after
his stroke to say he was in the hospital
and weeks to disclose a 2017 diagnosis
of cardiomyopathy another heart
condition
Pennsylvania voters are being asked to
elect a senator who just had a very
serious stroke they might be willing to
do so as long as they can make an
informed choice they have a right to
know whether what they saw in last
week's debate was simply a man
struggling with speech and auditory
processing or whether it was something
deeper if fetterman has test results
showing he has no cognitive impairment
he can easily put to rest any concerns
about his candidacy but if he has test
results that show cognitive impairment
and refuses to share that information
with voters that would qualify as
deception and that should render him
unfit for office regardless of the
effects of his stroke I'm Mark Thiessen
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
Jason and the house that Jason Chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as I take on American
Life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you download podcasts